وقد خل الرئيس الامريكي انه ورث فوضى
عارمه من اداره سلفه دوره ترامب مشيرا الى
انه تمكن من اعاده بناء الاقتصاد حتى
تستفيد منه الطبقات الفقيره والمتوسطه وفي
مقابله مع اذاعه بلاك امريكا انتقد
بايدينج جماعه ماغا المؤيده معتبرا انها
تشكل خطرا على الديمقراطيه وشدد على ان
هناك اكثر من 300 مرشح جمهوري في
الانتخابات النصفيه يشككون في نزاهه
الانتخابات ولا يعترفون بالخساره
واشار الرئيس الامريكي الى ان مجموعه ماجا
لا تمثل قيم الاباء المؤسسين للحزب
الجمهوري على حد تعبيره
وقال تائبه الرئيس الامريكي كامله حارس ان
هناك الكثير من الامور على المحك في
الانتخابات النصفيه مشيره الى انها تعمل
للحيوله دون سيطره الجمهوريين على
الكونجرس
وجددت هارس في تصريحات صحفيه دعوه
الامريكيين الى التوجه الى مكاتب الاقتراع
واعتبرت ان الخروج من التصويت يمثل جزءا
من الواجب الوطني والمسؤوليه الفرديه على
حد تعبيرها